chris is with us in Charlotte North
Carolina hi Chris how are you I'm
wonderful day talking to my hero how are
you doing better than I deserve sir
thank you very much how can I help
well I have a question where I have have
five kids I have a seven year old I have
five year old triplets and a three year
old whoa oh yeah been working your plant
for about seven years now since the
oldest was uh was born got out of that
when she was born wife was able to stay
at home she's a nurse so she's she's
been working one day a week and my
question is how do you how did you and
Sharron do it with your kids when you
when they were younger as far as being
away from the homework and going out you
know killing it and dragging it home
with the balance of family as well well
you you have to use two things one is
you have to have prioritize things that
you don't touch for instance you know
we're doing a lot of live events and
traveling around the country we were
fuse to book a speaking engagement on
one of my kids birthdays and so that I'm
there for the important things I don't
miss proms I didn't miss I didn't miss
Daniels ice hockey tournaments that kind
of stuff missed a few games here there
but I didn't miss the tournament and so
um you know they know that they're going
to look up and they're going to see us
at the important things and that they
are first so much so that we literally
planned our spring or fall schedule
around those things and you have to
prioritize that way if they see that
they'll give you a lot of tolerance on
being out a weekend or being out of the
evening or two here or there that kind
of stuff or missing some other things
that aren't as important that so that's
thing one is really pick out some things
that you make a priority thing to is
that this needs to ebb and flow you know
if you're busting it for 80 hours a week
or you're busting it for 70 hours a week
you can't do that for four years and
straight and never take a break and
expect your marriage or your kids to not
suffer that's not logical and so we kind
of use tides coming in tides coming out
as our approach and we still do I'm an
empty nester now Sharon's kind of like
don't you have someplace you need to go
and speak you know she's ready for me to
leave now but uh so but even that I need
to make sure that I've got you know time
with her and that we have time to travel
with just she and I are friends or
whatever that kind of thing separate
from work and so you know there'll be a
period of time like this year starting
August 30th until Thanksgiving I'm I'm
gonna be going a lot all right the house
is on fire I got a lot Chris Hogan
Christie right Rachel Cruise and I we're
going to be out Chris Brown we're going
to be doing all kinds of events all over
America we're going to be bustin it but
you know when I'm home then I'm home
right 100% and so turn off the stupid TV
when you're old
I don't want to take up too much time
but how as far as Sharon as Sharon was
concerned yet my wife is more of you
know we've been busting it for seven
years we haven't really got anywhere but
we have five kids how do you kind of get
her to keep the big picture in mind as
far as I've got to get out there and do
it in order to provide yeah does that
make that well there's a provide part of
it and then there's a prosper part of it
there's two sad things providing you got
to do whatever you got to do everybody's
got it right it's that simple
prospering beyond that is is a different
thing and you know it's not true to say
you haven't made progress in seven years
you told me you're out of that right
yeah you told me you had your emergency
fund and you got five kids right so you
have made progress Yeah right yeah
you're right you're right I just I don't
know I guess I just want more and bigger
and better you know I got a well when
she hears you say that she hears you say
you're never going to stop working like
an animal all right and you got to give
her some light at the end of tunnel that
okay yeah I'm gonna work like an animal
for this period of time then I'm gonna
take this time off and then I'm going to
work like an animal for this period of
time and then I'm going to take this
time off but when we started this
business 25 years ago I mean there were
three years I wasn't home period
and then I mean I was gone and working
12 14 hour days man I mean I was busting
it but nowadays I do whatever the flip I
want to do I know right and so and I did
then
but it was just for three years we said
we're going to give this we're going to
go crazy for three years and then we'll
raise this thing up we'll be able to
delegate we'll be able to slow down a
little bit and and you'll be able to
work work your way around it so she just
got to see that a you'll be there for
the prioritized things be when you're
home you're actually there you unplug
the smartphone in the computer and you
turn off the television and you're
actually there and and then see there
has to be this em and flow the tide
comes in then the tide goes out and so
I'm going to go hard for three months
then we're going to have three months
it's more of a normal pace and then I'm
gonna go hard for two months then we're
going to a month it's a normal pace and
just talk it through and you lay that
out and you because you don't want to go
a hundred percent 80 hour weeks I mean
the rest of your life that's just silly
that's not that's not fair to you even
it doesn't make sense good question
thanks for the call love a person that's
willing to work hard but also loves
their family and wants to find some kind
of reasonable balance I meet people all
the time to say the opposite and they're
like oh because of my family I can't
work more than about 30 hours a week and
I they have to be nurtured and you know
that nurturing is also called feeding
them so you are going to work more than
30 hours a week welcome to life that's
how it works out here in the real world